todd phillips the director of the
upcoming joker movie has publicly
revealed the first official look at
joaquin phoenix in the lead role the
surprisingly stripped-down image was
posted to philip's instagram page with a
one-word caption
arthur without the context of the
upcoming solo movie you'd never know
this was supposed to be a portrait of
the clown prince of crime
saved for a greasy hairstyle and a few
extra wrinkles
phoenix looks a lot like himself in the
photo but there's a reason for that
phillips who has directed films like old
school starsky and hutch and the three
movies of the hangover series
isn't making a movie about the joker at
the height of his powers instead
joker is expected to be a dark and
experimental story
reportedly centering around a failed
comedian in the 1980s who snaps and
transitions to a legendary life of crime
phoenix is playing the joker as an
everyday guy and this glimpse appears to
be from just before one of his bad days
sends him over the edge
with that in mind it makes sense that
the first reveal of phoenix in character
doesn't feature him in the typical joker
look here he's just a fairly normal dude
struggling to realize his dream of
making people laugh when he comes to
terms with the fact that his career may
never take off
he takes matters into his own hands in a
decidedly theatrical way
it sounds pretty relatable aside from
the whole domestic terrorism thing
phillips's big reveal seems to confirm a
previous report by that hashtag show
that stirred up a ton of hype
in july the outlet posted an article
claiming that the joker's real name in
the movie would be revealed as arthur
fleck
now that phillips himself has mentioned
the name it seems a sure bet that mr
fleck is our leading man
in the same write-up that hashtag show
also reported that the joker movie will
see arthur moving in with his sick
mother
penny and later meeting a woman named
sophie dumond who may be played by zazie
beats of atlanta and deadpool 2.
other reports would seem to corroborate
those details the outlet's most
outlandish hypothesis that the joker and
the batman will be revealed to be half
brothers has yet to be confirmed or
denied but we do know that batman's
father
thomas wayne will be a part of the movie
so perhaps there's some truth to that
tidbit
as well a major part of the joker's
appeal over the years has been his
generally unknown constantly shifting
origins aside from the 1989 batman movie
which presented the character as a
gangster named
jack napier the joker typically hasn't
been shown as having a traditional
backstory he's usually more of an agent
of chaos with a contradictory history
that he routinely lies about
you wanna know how i got these scars
despite that history of ambiguity the
fact that this movie appears to be
nailing down
one origin story for the joker isn't
anything to be alarmed about
it's not meant to be a definitive
interpretation just a different one
the fox series gotham a prequel of sorts
to the world of batman
has also spent the last few years
playing around with the joker inspired
characters
jerome and jeremiah veleska unhinged
villains who have frequently been teased
as potentially being younger versions of
the joker we know
but what's true in the world of gotham
doesn't need to be true for any other
batman story
and the same goes for this solo movie
unlike the shared universe occupied by
movies like suicide squad
wonder woman and justice league joaquin
phoenix's joker movie is set to be a
standalone film
existing outside of established
continuity to tell a radically different
story it's a new approach for dc comics
on screen
and if it works out we can probably
expect other alternate universe else
worlds type stories to follow like the
soviet union superman story
superman red sun this alternate universe
aspect is a big part of what makes
joker so potentially special it gives
phillips and phoenix the freedom to be
weird and takes chances without worrying
about sequels spin-offs or what's going
on in the batman movies
it's a great first look at one of 2019's
most curious projects
and we can't wait to find out more
you just couldn't let me go could you